oh hey how's going bros my name is peter
pan let's keep playing
heart of dare Canaries my shirt will
change last episode was the worst
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] ever and most
likely this will be the same kind of
experience this game is so hard
if you bros want to help me do like a
death count that'd be great cuz we're
gonna need it
alright we're gonna [ __ ] mean it here
we go okay so far so good
I can't believe I haven't died yet so
you gotta wait for them to eat there we
go
and I die we didn't even load the
[ __ ] next stream screen like this
game is not enough to troll me Jesus
Christ okay so I gotta I gotta wait for
them to eat their [ __ ] [ __ ] please go
ahead and eat your [ __ ] you gotta wait
for the green balls to hit eat them eat
it wanting to eat it there you go he eat
it so now we can jump on him or not one
foreign-born or not alright
[ __ ] okay here we go how do I jump to
him jeez ah [ __ ] stand on the other
okay here we go
jump jump starting to learn I'm like
near for the matrix it's starting to
believe okay come on bit there it is
I don't know how to do this [ __ ] par
let Edgar play okay that's a great idea
why wouldn't I see I can double jump
like this but if I do it horizontally
you need to back flick Jem yeah [ __ ]
what oh why didn't no one tell me
whatever all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] me God all right we're
gonna wait for them to eat anyway I
don't see how far I can walk out on this
alright here we go going [ __ ] my [ __ ]
Oh God
yeah what do I am where do i Jim help ah
gonna lose momentum soon Edgar oh yes oh
boy oh boy oh boy okay
okay I'm just gonna go oh god oh god oh
god and I'm dead alright cool yeah [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me oh you want this game is
worse than Dark Souls come on Go Go oh
and I'm dead and I'm [ __ ] awesome I'm
just gonna go this way
[ __ ] those guys excuse me oh are you
kidding me okay well then I don't know
what stop moving just run this is the
fastest he runs come on buddy and I get
[ __ ] come on go
come on go go bro I can duck no no Oh
miss ribbit ha ha miss me [ __ ] ha ha ha
ha Oh miss me [ __ ]
oh no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not
today [ __ ] not all got my ass is
showing my own nut today [ __ ] not today
not today [ __ ] go go go not today [ __ ]
not today that's right
oh not today not today [ __ ] that's
right can't [ __ ] me
not today [ __ ] not today
Oh what all the light kills them
gonna do it flip for that do it yeah
that's cool
doing good I'm pretty proud of myself ok
so here we got the glowing radioactive
butt hole and I think we should touch it
yes best game 2099 I dead alright
nevermind oh alright you can always go
somewhere where I don't know buddy
ok we're not gonna we're not gonna touch
the but right now we're gonna wait with
a but as much as I like touching the
blood we're not gonna do it am I the
only one that here like farts in the
background no I definitely hear farts in
the background grab the [ __ ] Leon you
piece of trash that was not funny okay
and that was my punishment okay I think
I know what we need to do we need to
grab this somehow
all right so that's what candy we're
gonna go when he's eating I don't know
what that does but I'm gonna assume it
does something then we're gonna go back
here and then we're gonna go here Oh God
help help ha ha yeah cool thanks
there it is beautiful and now we can go
past solving puzzles I'm not so smart I
say I mean I'm not so stupid as people
think I am
that's right oh my god holy [ __ ] what do
I do now
I get [ __ ] back please only me redo
everything please please please oh god
okay thanks thanks game come on eat them
why aren't they eating them oh it's
eating them okay now you eat the other
one and it Amy [ __ ] ass licking
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] go [ __ ] a duck in
the ass come on man you wanna eat the
flowers go eat the flowers man come on
man yeah that's right you dumb
[ __ ] we can do it eat it
Oh Oh saw Donny okay here we go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you eat it you're a dick
all right come on come on eat something
okay we did it oh so small then all
right now look at this suck my ass
suck my [ __ ] ass suck it suck it suck
my ass that's right you can't but I'm a
[ __ ] all right let's go here one step
at a time baby
no one step at a time better well it'd
be great if I could see anything
something would be great to see we
progressing so that's good but as soon
as I die we're gonna go back this is the
last thing you got to do this [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right all right
I'm guessing if we fall down that guy is
gonna [ __ ] us if we don't go in the lay
on I don't know what it's called in it
okay I don't know what it's called okay
this is our mine
oh oh go on the lien you said go in the
vine [ __ ] you oh my god never listening
to you bros again never oh my god
em to the [ __ ] G what is this rock
down here Jennifer stop [ __ ] me ah oh
how about this Jennifer it's something
wrong come on what are you waiting for
Jennifer what if I like these jokes are
inappropriate because the boys was we
like eight alright here we go
I'll climb that [ __ ] oh my god oh god
whoa what is going on oh my god yes a
cutscene the cutscenes are the [ __ ]
best Oh
we're friends back
and he's gone oh [ __ ] I was hoping we'd
be I was hoping we would be in like a
nice place like a nice new place listen
I didn't see Edgar all right
don't call Peter please oh oh and I died
awesome I think I've we got a swing here
right oh oh my god that was awesome this
game is so cool I can't believe oh god
swim for the love of God no time to talk
just got a swim this is my nightmare
being chased while swimming okay
thank God just gonna sit here this is
not worth it uh I'm enjoying this I mean
it really sucks getting stuck when you
livestream especially when you're shot
doesn't help you okay we go into the
tree I'm just gonna keep going up oh no
no thanks
No thank you I'll be here on this thing
oh my god uh okay let's go oh god which
way should we gentlemen
oh we helped him we helped Jar Jar Binks
hey hey Jar Jar
Andy's showing a little bit too much
stomach
keep falling
he just keeps falling George or save
this are you an acrobat but I'm [ __ ]
idiot
his name is amigo his name is amigo
what is going on
jaja bingo looks like he lost some
weight it looks [ __ ] hot I'm turned
on well turned on right now
what a derpy and goofy character George
Lucas was right it was right all along
sorry I loved that 40 million subs but
only 3,000 people watching I don't have
40 million subs on Twitch I don't know
if you knew that but I would like to so
please please sub that'd be great
all right so they're shooting fireballs
in the water what a [ __ ] idiots so I
think we made it a new area that's
awesome would I banged your Lucas yes I
would I had sex with the Frog once
before and it wasn't as bad as everyone
says okay I hope we're in a new area now
that'd be cool
we're gonna swim into the tentacles I
think we all know where this is going
and we get [ __ ] by the fire oh we have
to go down I'll make sure we get some
remote emotion modak ons some derp
emoticons oh that's great I'm glad we
did then
what do I do with this do I turn into a
frog resumption squeaking of frogs Matt
no you guys cannot touch my beard all
right
holy Mars I can touch my beard all right
let's week zoom deeper apparently we
have infinite health at was it called
health whatever oxygen bar oxygen supply
baby maybe we are a frog George Lucas
was right all along
you [ __ ] call that [ __ ] okay here we
go
oh dude this is like a galaxy cave and
we can never return again
oh my gum back okay ow
well that's not working okay well it
looks like we're trapped
[ __ ] what do I do
whoa I got a new power how did I get
this from the ball
I love balls I'm working that did I have
this power all along oh man
[ __ ] yeah whoa did I seriously have that
power all along and Eros didn't tell me
I must have been talking about be
looking up pika hey what's that killing
killing killing killing it killing it
come on stop [ __ ] balls man weird
okay
what do we use it what do I do die
whoa-oh Skellig ain't blows my mind yeah
that's awesome balls man go forth my
ball
I believe in your balls see grow grow my
ball and but I just get [ __ ] eaten by
piranhas oh I know what we need to do
okay I think I know what we need today
shoot the ball and then do it again and
it's gonna fall over as a bridge nailed
it
okay do you think we can reach do you
bros think we can reach yeah [ __ ] yeah
four balls that thing looks disgusting I
gotta say no come on game oh I think I
wouldn't die
I hate those troll of deaths it's
pissing me up so bad are we gonna go
down here I guess please don't kill me a
pot of death and suffering we great
really appreciate it what the [ __ ] are
those damn Daniel oh great I got sucked
out and spit out come on
let's wait for him go go go go go swim
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and learn to swim all right thank you
here we go come on come on come on come
on come on swim yeah okay now what gotta
wait for the right moment swim like the
wind baby whoa ah got some fresh breath
air that's been here for hundreds of
years so good oh god oh god there's the
stream sand [ __ ] there's a stream in the
stream brush what do I know there's a
stream of the stram god damnit never go
double stream never oh [ __ ] me I gotta
do that again
doesn't seem very likely oh god please
don't kill me ya know that totally
worked
oh my god yes oh that sucked
literally okay we did it
there we go oh god there's more more
tentacles how many tentacles can they
put in a [ __ ] game Oh God
oh we're not [ __ ] up now holy [ __ ]
thank you for us thank you great no no
no please for the love of God please
well I hope you enjoyed this live stream
it was a lot of fun really enjoyed it oh
my god did we have the best time ever
oh boy oh boy oh boy
I press thank you for watching this
video really appreciate it
next one is right there but before you
go go ahead and leave a like and I'll
see you bros and the next one stay
awesome rabid a bat bat bat app that bad
bit about that book over the edge and
when I
it's not going to do anything but things
with that attitude